did I've got contractors at the house
and I think I told one of them to drop
dead I'm like that's not language what
why because they're contractors and
they're all criminals yeah because he's
being lied to and over because because
they're Liars that you let into your
house and then they rob you I'm going to
do this wrong a bunch of times yeah and
I'm going to charge you too much for the
thing I did wrong and then disappear for
months at a time 4 and a half months for
a bathroom that happened to me where
they left in the middle of construction
yeah after they tear everything down and
they went and took another job cuzz now
they got you right and then they came
back and I almost lost my goddamn mind
you know the the sink's Crooked the
faucet and the showers crooked the
toilet leaks I'm like you guys there's
four people here doing this and you all
looked at what each other did and said
good job let's go get some
beers they just screwed up everything
and finally I was talking to one guy
like hey you want to come back for the
fifth time and maybe do it right this
time well if you're already upset I'm
I'm like yeah I'm upset well we got
other jobs do I'm like yeah this is one
of them